yes I now know in the trailer she said
kitchen you don't have to keep telling
me so before we get into the premiere of
the new series of Doctor Who I want to
talk a little bit about bill the new
companion about one of two new
companions but nardole who's the other
one we've already seen before so I don't
need to speculate about what we'll get
with him we know we're getting persons
began I like it now bill I have had
concerns about up to this point and I
haven't tucked a ton about her
explicitly or at least did like at the
main focus of a video I brought her up
when she's showing up in trailers and
teasers and went on like I said I
something about the vibe of it hasn't
been quite clicking for me now
BBC put out a video that was a little
bit of a behind the scenes with the
actress Pro Mackey and Peter Capaldi and
Steven Moffat all talking about the
character sort of what the concept
behind her is in some of the background
on her and that video has not completely
made my concerns go away but it's made
me a little bit more hopeful that I will
actually enjoy her as a character some
of the specific things that they brought
up one of the big things actually was
that that she is a bit of a sci-fi geek
so that means that she's coming at this
and these experiences not from oh my god
I never conceived of this angle book
from like somebody like me and I think a
lot of the fans of this show we'd be
like oh this is kind of like that or you
know we'd have a point of reference that
would be an easy enough for us to grasp
it that the questions we would ask
wouldn't be the obvious questions they'd
be more off-kilter questions so I like
that as a bit of her concept I also it
actually helped me seeing Pro Mackey
talked to the camera and just as an as a
person give off a completely different
vibe from the vibe that I get of her
playing bill and that to me says that
she is a good actress and she's not they
didn't just cast her because she is the
thing that she's doing they're casting
her because she can perform it well
because they're did their did at least
to me appear to be a pretty big
difference between how she came across
as a person and how will the character
of bill comes across so that is
reassuring to me it tells me that they
have gotten a good actress in the part
not that I was necessarily concerned
that they
but sort of having that confirmed in a
way is a nice thing that gives me some
more hope I like sort of they put four
that she's got to challenge the doctor a
bit more and gonna come at things from
an angle he's not expecting which is
something I've liked about some past
commands it was something I really liked
about Donna for example so there were a
lot of things said in that that made me
go okay
I like the idea behind Bill does that
mean I'm gonna like her as a character
not necessarily because there is a
difference between a character that
works on paper and how it actually ends
up in in the end because a lot of things
can happen I mean it can just be case of
maybe the chemistry is off something
about the execution doesn't quite work
while the central concept might be a
good idea the specific writing in terms
of characterization a dialogue might not
be to my particular liking or it could
just be in case that they execute
exactly what was on paper but it just
turns out boy that didn't gel the way on
paper one would think that it would have
and all of that is still possible
because as I said the footage that I've
seen up to this point has made me go I
don't know and that feeling isn't now
totally gone but I'm more hopeful that
she'll be able to turn me around because
I now get the idea behind the character
I get what they're going for and that is
a good thing for me to know cuz I think
initially sort of especially like seeing
or working at cafeterias serving chips
and immediately brought back memories of
rose yes I understand her serving chips
was just an undercover thing in a school
reunion I get that but it it was an
image that I always had of rose so I was
immediately getting that oh they're just
kind of doing rose again vibe and now
that I get the concept behind what she
how she's supposed to work and her
dynamic and her background a little bit
and she comes from a rougher background
but she still hasn't upbeat spirit and
upbeat personality these are all things
that I am down with in concept so no I
am on board with the concept of bill I
think hopefully gets me in a mindset
where I'll be more accepting and for
what she actually shows up on screen and
one less thing I'm just gonna mention to
bring up the fact why I haven't talked
about it up to this point the fact that
it has been revealed Oh
potential spoilers if you've really been
trying to avoid a lot of information I
don't know if it's a spoiler I don't
know if it
factor into the story at all but I just
in case the thing that I haven't talked
about is Bill is apparently gonna be the
first openly gay companion and the
reason I haven't brought it up is it
doesn't impact my feelings about the
character specifically one way or the
other it doesn't make me automatically
more disposed to her it doesn't make me
dislike her I do like that we're getting
that level of representation into the
show I think as a general thing a a
recurring character who is like V
Central Command cuz obviously we've had
Jack Harkness who's more kind of an omni
sexual for lack of a better term but you
know he's also from a different time a
different culture where what he is is
actually normal so the idea of having
somebody from today who is openly gay I
think that's it and and also that she's
a woman obviously Jack Harkness was a
man I think that's just a nice bit of
representation it's nice to have it on
there in terms of will it make me more
accepting to the character it doesn't
impact things either way that's why I
didn't bring it up of course now I
brought up the fact that I didn't bring
it up meaning I made a deal out of the
fact that I didn't make a deal out of it
thereby making a deal of it oh this just
goes around around around does it
anyways that's my thoughts my concerns
and my hoaxes about Bill what are your
thoughts on her about a Pro Mackey's
performance as her about the idea behind
the character whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give it a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]